6 40 it is wednesday
time for morning cup of joe with metro
sheriff joe lombardo good morning
sheriff it's great to have you
good i'm looking at myself on camera i'm
a little casual today
yeah casual wednesday looks good all
right sheriff
we know you just tell the state of the
department what are some of the
department's goals for this new year
yeah we did unfortunately we couldn't do
it in a public venue because of cobit
obviously
so we did it virtually similar to the
governor's state of the
state and i think it went over well
hopefully
you've had a chance to watch it but in
the previous years
i have concentrated on violent crime as
our priorities and then last year
included quality of life on top of
violent crime and i think i'm going to
continue in that vein will
not think i know i'm going to continue
in that vein moving forward to 2021
violent crime and quality of life and
you know and through the state of
department we talked about
the department's response to covid last
year and you know coming into the 21
and how we dealt with that and
unfortunately we've had over 1200
employees infected with covid and
but we've been pretty successful and as
essential
employees or essential folks within the
community in responding to crime
dealing with those numbers unfortunately
we had
two employees succumb to covid
and i'm pleasantly surprised how we
dealt with it going forward
we developed a new strategic plan um and
the strategic plan is basically our
blueprint
on how we conduct ourselves on a daily
basis and and what our goals are
looking into the future and and how
we're going to fight crime which is our
mission
um as a police department uh we
talked about police reform you know the
stuff we went through in 2020 and
i anticipate we're going to have to deal
with at this legislative session here in
21
all the things associated with the
communities clamoring for police reform
and doing business better
i'm very proud that we have minimal
changes
in the way we do business here at metro
because a lot of those things were
brought forward
in years past uh you know things like
de-escalation and duty to render aid and
and limiting the choke hold uh those
type of items
and then we talked about the budget uh
you know
just like everybody else has gone
through and what las vegas as a whole is
experiencing
how do we deal with the budget
shortfalls um did i have to lay off
employees i unfortunately i had to lay
off some civilian employees
we we got rid of all our part-time
employees we got rid of a couple
specialized programs and we had to
downsize a significant number of
programs
throughout the police department
hopefully through 21 and 22
23 we can recover uh some of those
programs that are essential in what we
do in the police business
so moving forward to 21 homelessness and
mental health
that along with violent crime and that
quality of life is homeless
mental health how we respond to a police
department how we
help the community develop resources in
response to those two particular issues
uh so those are going to be on the
forefront of what we deal with in 21.
you know sheriff speaking of violent
crime according to metro stats homicides
doubled
just last month compared to the same
time last year what do detectives
believe is behind that increase
well fortunately it's only been four
weeks you know
the same time last year so if you move
into february
and year to date we're actually flat
so unfortunately those numbers have
recovered
from the previous year so we were
doubled up in january
and there was no trend identified
you know we've seen we've seen an
increase in violent crime across the
board
across the united states in 2020 and a
lot of
there could be a lot of reasons for that
prison reform
bail reform prosecution
inability because of the closure of the
courts
covet anxiety there's a lot of people
out there theorized
associated with that but my goal is just
to address it
and i think we did a robust job i know
we did a robust job
in addressing that particular issue uh
because we were down
four percent in violent crime compared
to last year the thing i'm most proud of
though is our homicide detail
our homicide investigation our
solvability was right around 92 percent
and if you look at the national average
it's around 62 percent
so that's a lot of lives in that 30
percent delta
associated with that number and and i
think we are the industry standard best
practice
agency uh associated with those type of
investigations
yeah 92 that's really that's great uh
sheriff we know like everything else
super bowl weekend was a lot different
this year
from metro standpoint were there less
issues in terms of dui
no there was less issues as far as crowd
sizes and dealing with crowds and things
that go along with crowds such as
uh you know fighting and as you can
imagine
i don't need to uh tell you about that
but the uh what we did have an increase
was
uh dui enforcement we didn't do check
points this year
we find out those are very limiting in
their in their results
and so we did a lot of saturation
patrols
so we had a 60 increase in dui
arrests and we had a 84 increase
in citations issued so we uh we were
very busy
on super bowl weekend associated with
dui
and the reason why we uh i'm actually
proud of that number because
duis more often than not result in a
fatal accident
and if we can get those individuals off
the roadway and prevent a fatal accident
the better we all are yeah and
unfortunately we report on that far too
often so
good to hear those stats all right
sheriff joe lombardo thank you so much
for joining us
hope you're doing well you too alex
thank you thank you and if you have a
question for sheriff joe lombardo you
can send a test
just go on our website newsnow.com we do
our morning cup of just segments every
wednesday so that would be when your
question is answered
all right